Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche !
Bonjour à toutes les Épicurieuses
et tous lesÉpicurieux.
Aujourd'hui c'est mercredi,
comme chaque mercredi je réponds aux questions
que vous m'avez posées avec #DisJamy
Une question de Rock girl
à propos descucurbitacées :
" La citrouille est-elle un fruit ou un légume ?"
Alors d'un point de vue botanique,
lacitrouille est un fruit tout simplement
parce qu'elle se forme à partir d'une fleur
commela tomate d'ailleurs,
la prune ou la cerise.
Mais d'un point de vue culinaire,
on parle de lacitrouille comme d'un légume
parce qu'on ne la consomme pas en dessert
mais plutôt en soupe.
Dureste,
on trouve les citrouilles dans les potagers
alors que les fruits, eux,
sont récoltés dansles vergers.
Une question de Majin
concernant la vidéo sur les feuilles d'automne :
" J'ai un arbrechez moi qui jaunit mais dont les feuilles ne tombent pas.
Pourquoi ? "
Alors c'est effectivement lecas de certains arbres et arbustes comme le charme ou le rhododendron.
On dit que ces arbressont marcescents.
Alors ça ne signifie pas que les feuilles ne tombent pas.
Le charme parexemple va garder ses feuilles flétries
pendant tout l'hiver.
C'est la saison du repos végétatif
mais elles vont finir par tomber au printemps
quand les nouvelles feuilles vont repousser.
Les nouvelles vont pousser les anciennes.
Une question d'Atox sur la vidéo des marées :
" Si lesoleil, la lune et la Terre sont alignés, pourquoi n'assistons pas à une éclipse ? "
Alors quand la Terre, la lune et le soleil sont alignés,
on assiste à une marée de vives-eaux.
Cet alignement correspond
effectivement à celui d'une éclipse.
Mais pour que celle-ci ait lieu,
la lune doit se trouver dansce qu'on appelle
le plan de l'écliptique
c'est-à-dire le plan dans lequel la Terre
tourneautour du soleil.
Si elles se trouvent un peu au-dessus
ou un peu au-dessous,
ce qui se produitla plupart du temps,
il n'y a pas d'éclipse.